welcome to this video yeah this is about
round form of Tata Steel 2013 anthem the
round even is not yet finished but I'll
start my video anyway because I'll do
only one game of this round for now the
thing is that this round is some has
produced far more interesting chess in
one round than all three rounds before
that put together we've got seven games
total in the top group and of course and
there's some there probably will only be
just one draw which has been uneventful
but the other six games have been a very
interesting three us the running and I
probably do just this is the one game
I'm going to show and this is Aronian
against them or not but maybe I'll do
some highlights of the other games in a
separate video simply but not today
maybe tomorrow or some some other day
because it's simply too much it also
wouldn't make any sense to look at a
game like the game from Magnus which is
still running against Harry Krishna and
this looks super complicated to me it
doesn't make any sense to to do this in
like five minutes
and you never understand anything in
this in this time I won't understand
anything and probably spectators also so
let's just look at Aronian against Anand
one deform the sloth can we get to the
semi sloth which has been a main part of
Arlen's opening repertoire for yeah
basically his whole chess Korean team
has played this since the early 90s and
Aronian was going for III um I'm not
100% sure what his main moves are here I
think III is
is what he usually plays Bishop g5
allowing him the Moscow and he Moscow he
probably played this as well but III is
probably more coming in his repertoire
and but I think he usually goes for
Queen c2 now we will have a
transposition but okay Bishop d3 the
Marilyn variation black captured and
played b5 and Bishop d3 yeah here's an
interesting point black has two main
options here with an a6 which is the old
line the classical line dating back to
the days of Alaska and Rubinstein from
the 1920s and 30s
efore c5 so what usually follows and
this is has been a point of discussion
in the World Championship Mitch match
that Alan played against kramnik in 2008
thereon and played a six
he also played Bishop d7 which is the
main move and what he played in the game
Bishop d6 is some the latest wrinkle so
to say and this move only has gotten
some popularity in the last couple of
years it's pretty logical nevertheless
the ideas to put this Bishop on d6
preparing a five especially in response
to right playing efore and trying to
threaten this this Fork and sometimes
the bishop is useful on c8 you don't
necessarily need to fianchetto it all
the time
okay but let's start stick to theory too
much castles castles and here White has
two main options he can go for 44 after
which black plays e5 of course needs to
prevent the e5 move from forking the two
pieces and here
white has some many options Bishop g5 is
one idea which could be on something
like this and now we see that the bishop
in fact has some function it may be
support some piece going to G form I
didn't go to G for itself so on a
completely different position Aronian
played Queen c2 and this actually
transposes to a line stemming from six
Queen c2 so Queen c2 in this position
instead of instead of Bishop d3 and here
black can also has more than one move
from between a Bishop d7 assist normal
and white now goes a three you're just a
good a good preparation for a further
play on the Queen side what white I
would like to do in an ideal scenario he
was play maybe B form to prevent any
kind of C 65 advance and therefore
making the b7 bishop look I'm a bit
silly this is one idea of course a3 also
is a useful move for directed against
the black playing B 5 B form it gets
very concrete how quickly rook c8 is
that's what was played now and in this
position white plate um Iranian plate
the very interesting move on Knight to
g5 in fact instead of Knight g5 there
has been a number of tries before for
example white coats play the Musa B form
which looks am completely logical of
course this was the idea
in fact them after B form black has got
the amazing move available C 65 which
looks like utter nonsense but in fact it
is playable and probably am
one of the best and most as particular
novelties of recent times introduced
them last year by Muslim cousin John off
as black Andrew some is some one of them
on on seconds so you can guess that they
analyze this in much detail I don't want
to show so much about this this is
mostly a theoretical theoretical
question what what's happening here
it continues B takes e5 Bishop takes a
three G takes f three if I'm not
mistaken she takes a three and then
black can sacrifice on c5 in this in
this kind of position
he's got the combined ideas of Knight d5
putting pressure on this night and the
Taking Chances on the kingside and this
is actually a first draw at the end if
I'm not not wrong here okay
this was introduced on the last year
couple of month ago so let's return this
means that before which has been the
principal trifle white in this position
of course it's um yeah out of business
and white needs to look for some other
idea and Aronian came up as mentioned
with Knight g5 yeah my g5 is not an
uncommon idea in this opening the ideas
to UM can win a temple on on the h7
square on this poem and also introduced
the idea of playing Knight e4 which
would help to increase the group on the
c5 square to exchange one pair of
Knights for example the knight on f3
doesn't do anything in regards to the c5
square and it's really all about this
break if white manages to to prevent
this c5 break then probably he will be a
much better
the thing is 95 phone has got some
technical implications the first being
what about bishop takes hm
and this is also the most logical move
that you would think of first probably
because frankly speaking 95 looks like a
tactical blunder yeah that's um not the
case actually but um not easy to see
King takes h2 nitrogen one check came
back Quinn takes and now the idea of all
this is f3 Knight Returns and you form
this was White's idea and this idea is
well known in this opening as mentioned
not in this specific position this
specific position has been played in
fact only once and now uh in fact them
after f3 Knight f6 the game mentioned it
was a befall it was played this is a
game on from 2012 and this is void Tasha
cratis laughs what a check against by
malian AG we have what a check against
Neji and if you know a bit of a
background here what a shake is also one
of the seconds of Anand Anand team
consists of Kazakh jonov were taschek
and Peter Heine Neilson
so what a shake is also yeah closely
connected to to Anand and Nietzsche the
black player is also from India and is
also doing training sessions with Russia
so that we have some whoops some horses
was jumping back here
um and so both players are involved with
with Anand so he certainly know the
Knight g5 moves it didn't come as a
surprise and in fact after 95 I should I
should probably Queen g5f three takes
takes explain what what is going on here
white
actually has some excellent compensation
in this position just because of this
very stupid Bishop on b7 he sacrificed
this age to pawn but white will probably
even go a foreign later and it's not
easy to see how this Bishop should get
into play again on b7 so this is some
not very nice to play as some as black
there's even possibilities like let's
say Queen edge form and white can even
think about going into the endgame just
to play against this this terrible piece
white has very good compensation for the
pawn
probably not the best line is just to
show that this is a great important
suspicion so in the game Nazi father
Anna didn't take on h2 in fact look at
the clock times they both them basically
had to be lit up to this point yeah Anna
played the quite spectacular move I
think
c5 which is automatic of course but of
course a new in this position and what
is this move doing it immediately freeze
this Bishop which is good news but on
the other hand does a couple of other
things
it lets this this pawn completely
hanging could be taken by by two pieces
and also of course and more importantly
at the age seven I mean h7 was attacked
and black simply ignores this to add an
amazing concept and we see what what's
happening after some consideration I
think of sure both the clock times oh no
pretty pretty quickly aronia took on h7
so he had this head this anticipated I'm
sorry I'm someone I'm not sure it
somehow it just jumps back to to
something else just a second
okay so this this jumping back to Arthur
games shouldn't happen anymore sorry
so night xh7 is what Aronian played and
pretty quickly so this was maybe part of
the preparation here White had
alternatives of course and this is
mostly the move Bishop takes h7 check
which looks quite interesting
okay black cast only one movie needs to
go King a jade and now in this position
the move f4 which is probably necessary
to cement this night on g5 um simply
also blacks counter play is very quickly
with Bishop takes h2 threatening you
need to break this diagonal and after a
far I'm not quite sure what black should
play I mean its position is certainly
interesting and probably okay but it's
not completely self-evident what what's
the best move at least them my quick
analysis wasn't really conclusive what
what black should do here one funny
point is if black tries Queen to b6
putting pressure on the d5 pawn then
White has the very strong move d5 and
this is some actually already winning
the problem is if black captures and
there are some this idea rook f3 2 H 3
and this is probably just over at least
that it's pretty cleared one touch for
white this attack on the H father's is
too strong Queen b6 is not working what
black could try and would lead to a very
chaotic plays g6 of course trying to win
this bishop white needs to sacrifice him
and after Queen g6 um yeah maybe move
like we need
check and I'm really not sure what's
what's happening here
quite quite unclear and complicated
maybe it's good for white it's it's very
very difficult to say blacks King of
course is an issue but on the other hand
white also has pieces that don't really
play at the moment those especially they
don't country
contribute contribute too much to to the
game while blacks pieces are all in play
bishops the knight has has possibilities
not instantly of course a determines
made but no black has saw pieces in play
and white doesn't so I'm not quite sure
what to make of this but white has some
I think three points right
four yeah three parts already and yeah
it's pretty unclear hard to tell so g6
is one possibility and also black can
take on d4 and then play Queen b6
preventing this d5 idea and then
probably it continues something like
this which should be three and you know
Knight to d5 Knight to g4 it's a very
very hard to come to some conclusion
yeah it's probably not terrible for
black because it's it was prepared by
Ireland but it's hard to tell what
exactly is is going on i I suspect
though that Bishop takes a just heaven
was the best better move in comparison
to what was played in the game in the
game aronia took on age seven and Anand
now went 94 in fact after 10 minutes so
this is quite curious already maybe he
couldn't remember his analysis but this
is speculation I'm not sure how much of
this game was prepared and how much was
was played over over the board really
and since hard too hard to tell Nachi
for sell a move that you need to
yeah yeah think about a bit what what
are the implications really of course
the first move you you need to check is
what if white takes the rook this and
this fortunately is this is eg check
like capture cm and Queen h4 is yeah
immediate an immediate finish made to
come cannot prevent this we should check
with checkmate next so white cannot take
on f8 immediately so what should he do
it's not at all easy there are lots of
ways to instantly lose the game g3 it's
a move here you could think of breaking
this diagonal and yeah what now
black has funky-looking news and Queen
Queen h4 it's a funny move white would
take you've got the shield checkmate but
of course what if it isn't isn't forced
to take and he actually has the the move
f3 which now attracts lots of stuff and
black probably needs to second g3 and
itself
unfortunately entirely incorrect so
Queen h4 is not working but what black
can do is he can take on h2 and this is
strong the issue being that you cannot
take because checkmate this mate yeah
the two bishops are simply brilliant on
the diagonals so what cannot take and
black is also threatening Knight f3
check winning instantly so if you would
take now for example then white would
check lose his queen with this discover
check and yeah after Knight takes h2
what needs to go through enormous
lengths to not lose the game instantly
sorry this
not an option allowing the sacrifice um
what I will plate is probably wrong
probably ahead because it simply so
complicated that it's are too hard to
say with 100% certainty he played an F
form after a couple of minutes it seems
after some analysis but don't I wouldn't
bet substantial amounts of money on that
that maybe age three is the critical
test of all this but this leads to
complications that I'm really AM yeah
almost impossible to to figure out my
main line of quick analysis runs we
should teenage to check King here and
Queen to h4 which has to be adhered to
amongst others take on h3 to use this
pin of the diagonal and why probably
needs to to break this pin and define
this is one possible move to to do that
of course all this looks looks crazy in
some way because black has some already
he's got the rukon pre on f8 and this
this piece configuration is yeah
something like yeah set up with no
return in a way because it this Bishop
on h2 is completely loose it's just
covered by the night on g4 which is
hanging it's only technically covered
and the knight retreats the bishop is
gone if you put the bishop back you
don't know why you gave this cheque it's
an it's completely technical there's
nothing resembling any any sort of logic
or anything it's just pure calculation
but okay messages would be d5 to break
this this diagonal if Whitewood would
take on FA just just for fun sake then
there's really this move and here you
get you get destroyed
if white um breaks this diagonal then
you simply drop back and you've got this
move coming winning the game it's a bit
more complicated but I don't want to
make three hours of this um yeah white
probably should break this diagonal so
d5 would be a one possibility the other
being Bishop reform so also I'm also
interesting and here probably just this
cool move group ft8 secured this this
rook form from capture and see what
what's happening next
in fact them it gets some it gets more
wild even whiter for instance can go
Bishop e2 just just a sample line there
should be to Knight d2 e5f form and then
black can just goes here and this is
entirely unclear I mean do you
understand anything of this
I don't you can look at it with the
computer or you can spend a couple of
days to figure out what what's really
going on probably in this line some
together with Bishop takes h7 check it's
the critical point of all this but it's
very difficult to figure out really with
only a limited time on your hands so
maybe he needed to go h3 but I'm not
sure he played f4 which i think is
probably wrong but it's it's hard to
tell
Sylvia because also of the time spent
the curry of thing is what Anna
now he thought for about 45 minutes and
then took on d4 which is really weird
because yeah this some should be part of
his preparation so why is he thinking
for 40 minutes I mean I'm not I wouldn't
be surprised if you would invest like 10
minutes but 40 minutes is it's quite a
lot
it's all kinds of possibilities he could
have forgotten his analysis or for some
reason he really didn't know what was
going on his stumbled into this but it's
it's really hard to believe that this
was all conceived over the board
considering what is following now and
this is really something something else
umm.yeah Aronian now after some or
quickly
no he just instantly took okay in fact
him um Knight xf8 doesn't seem to to
lose outright to me so it it seems like
like an alternative actually um the
computer didn't find anything better
than Bishop takes takes here and then
you've got the funny move knight Knight
to c5
yeah some quite quite hard to grasp at
first at what this move is doing but
after D takes e5 Bishop c5 the bishops
um get to this devastating positions and
this is made g3 checkmate got this made
yeah the the bishops are simply great on
the on this neighboring diagonals 95 has
quite a move but it's not not the end of
the world actually White has a defense
which is if you ask me possible to see
beforehand
Bishop h7 King here and 21 this is the
kind of move you can you can easily miss
I mean you think about this what takes
here 95 you need to see you need to see
you cannot take it and then you need to
see that any Queen takes d4 is terrible
threat also you need to see that this
Bishop h7 king and queen d1 actually
keeps you in the game so this is
basically impossible to see even for
2800 player
I mean sometimes on a good day and some
luck you they might see it but it's it's
really difficult um yeah what is going
on here it's probably a better for black
anyway King takes Queen takes check
takes him and 93 and Black has a
tremendous position for for the exchange
with those kind of threats in fact she's
something like this after some
calculation time Houdini gives us
completely equal equal so yeah sometimes
you feel you know nothing about chess
it's clear that black has some
significant compensation but why this
exactly equal it's hard to tell
um what I'm getting at is night text
ahead was an alternative but due to this
pair of moves Knight c5 check it kicking
Queenie one impossible for y2 to see
really if you ask me pattern how to see
he took on deform a fter which are not
quickly played and if you see this move
then hats off to you maybe I'm I'll let
you think about this for a while but I
don't think there's someone coming up
with this he played the great roof
Bishop c5 and this is really am really a
an amazing amazing idea I mean I'm not
quite sure that I've seen something like
this it's it's it's really weird what
black is doing okay he's threatening to
take on D form let's think about this in
an abstract fashion but what else is
going on if white would take the rook
let's start with this to make the first
channel the first of the simple things
we have this stuff again and black wins
with with checkmate right this is easy
cannot take the rook so I'm not quite
sure I cannot why I cannot go back here
just a second I think I for whatever
reason I am I butchered this game oh
just a second okay I'm back at technical
problem here but it is soft now so on
vision ethics f8 was easy but okay what
about what about this Bishop isn't it's
just hanging of course it is
if white would take then yeah black
simply recaptures and what's going on
now it's hanging there squeegee for
coming
and still that's the rookie on evade so
what's going on actually it seems to
lead to to the to the next position I'm
almost by force white would take prolly
kucik King and now Knight takes and here
black has this threat coming so he only
can be stopped with age free to to win
immediately nice check and what needs to
return the exchange takes I'm sorry does
he need to return the exchange let me
let me check this quickly
yeah probably needs to take this is
check this is this is not checkmate not
very nice okay you have to take jinx
takes and here probably just King takes
of eight you to get there get the
material back and okay through some kind
of miracle we have a position with equal
material but black has yeah the much
better
um activity it's got the great p7 bishop
against the stupid piece and
everything's in play a black while white
has some steeping pieces here so black
has considerable advantage maybe this
was still better than what happened in
the game but I mean if you look at this
you cannot really go for for this
position it's just it's just terrible to
play him probably he just figured okay
I'll play in another way and give like
some chances to were wrong because this
line was really am relatively easy to
see DC 595 Queen deform he played Bishop
to e2 attacking
is this night and the answer is also
just a great move NAT D to e5 and this
is just just great just from from from
for aesthetics and just just find this
this amazing to put the night on this
erm double controlled square this also
covers the G form and you can now look
at various captures and they simply
don't work so wide I mean D takes e5
check out the Queen D form this was of
course the idea to open up the Queen for
deform and this simple okay this is
check the classic checkmate smothered
mate so on one needs to take but after
Queen takes there's the threat on g2 and
White has no way to to prevent this g2
and also Queen e1 it's also checkmate
and as mentioned no way to prevent it
like it's mating in two or three moves
here so it cannot take the bishop um
yeah of course D takes d5 it's not
working and what about fjx d5
this is Jack checkmate this mate coming
so 95 great move so what should Y - you
can also think about h3 attacking more
pieces but this can be answered by
Bishop takes the King here and now Queen
to h4 threatening Queen takes h3 with
mate and yeah what can what do we can
cover h3 in this way and now black has
more than one way to to win the game
one possibility is even rook takes c3 of
my computer likes but probably there
also
yes simpler ways to to do it um
for example let's like let's have a look
forgive the check this is probably
enough even getting getting the exchange
Whitewood to boot a con on the e5 now
there's check this move leading to
checkmate
check check Nate yeah quite quite a
number of mates these bishops really
guarantee for some some great attacking
lines so this was a position in the game
and Aronian decided to take on g4 and
now Bishop takes d4 with check Chang
Qing and Knight XG from and let's pause
for a moment material is equal so it
seems like again like a miracle of
TARDIS that there's no material great
material imbalance but of course the
question is what what is white doing
with this 90m like a threatening just
creates for winning and white took on f8
this is not so much because you want to
get the rook but you want to prevent
Queen to age form this was the problem
um if white would play some nothing
moves and Queen h4 is simply made if you
would play my g5 which you could could
think about not taking then black has
the strong move f5 very strong the idea
is rook f6 to h6 and white cannot take
on e6 of course again due to Queen h4
and made next move even that's not even
some spycheck availab
f-five is very strong and the amazing
thing is white took on a fate and the
same thing is working they even without
the rook are not now went f5 and this
way
preparing Queen edge form you could not
go Queen h4 immediately because of Queen
h7 and white saves himself at least it's
no mate yeah something like this what
would happen and black has has something
but it's not winning huh why anything
the thing is you just have this
greatness f5 you just ignore this night
and go with the threat
Queen to h4 and White has absolutely no
way to prevent it those two bishops of
course and some sort of echo of the
classic game rock levy against
Rubinstein from I think in 1923 from
1920s at least where those two bishops
won with similar mating ideas okay
and now yeah what should should why do
Queen h4 as the threat and there's
really no way to to go about this he
went Nagi six to prevent Queen h4 but
now on adjust could play Queen f6 note
he is playing all this almost instantly
now after he spent those close to fifty
minutes on on the one position now is
playing all this this quickly Queen f6 h
three yeah there's no way to secure the
the night if you move it then like has
the nice move Knight takes h2 this also
other moves that probably win but this
is the strongest the idea is just to
threaten Queen h4 and then this
discovery and white has no way to
prevent it
simply cannot cover this this square
even yeah and the game we played h3 yeah
no she just took took the night of
course this is covered YouTube checkmate
this checkmate or queen h6 just the same
cannot take again a knob like simply
threatens Queen h5 and taking on h3
blood went Queen e2 Queen h5 threatening
dismayed and yeah it's a it's simply
over blacker has some these strong
bishops to Queen f3
it's it's impossible to to prevent it
what you could do to avoid the immediate
mate is its rook f3 but it also leads to
a pretty hopeless situation black and
take check 9f to check and here black
could could take on c3 with a big
advantage or after takes he can be to go
here which would also be a terrible
position for what
why does almost in some sort of suits
one cannot move anything he off the
Queen side and he will lose material
here this is in fact completely hopeless
it's materially equal but it's no way to
to save this to save this position
because white can simply not move um of
course this would have prolonged the
fight a bit Aronian went Queen d3 and
after the cute move Bishop e3 he
resigned as now Queen takes takes h3
it's absolutely impossible to to prevent
so great a quick win and hi by the world
champion and certainly the most
inspiring game that he has played and
maybe like two or three years yet it's
great to see him when a nice
game really because he's such a yeah a
good friendly guy let that you sort of
wish for him to perform well at least
that this applies for me like him to
perform well but of course you need to
UM CAD you need to it you need to play
well it's not being nice doesn't help
okay so a great performance it would be
interesting to to see or hear what what
they say about the preparation of the
game because the actual game if you look
at this starting with mu 13 only took
about ten moves on the critique the
critical moves out thirteen fourteen and
more maybe fifteen
so this basically decided the game and
would be nice to him up to which point
they did some preparation for Aronian
it's obviously a disaster to walk into
this and for Anand I mean it's hard to
believe with so many people from his
camp involved that he he didn't prepare
this in such detail but his curious that
he really invested if you look at this
yeah he invested like more than forty
minutes forty eight minutes on the
smooth even if you forgot your analysis
it's it's curious that he would spend so
much time it's of course possible that
that he could have thought out CDE that
that he could have sauce in this over
the board this is possible I mean he
sees one of the greatest players ever I
mean why shouldn't he be able to see
this and it's just how to believe that
he would need to see it just two or
three moves after we leave established
theory but with people involved that he
knows um yeah nevertheless a great game
whatever part the preparation was on
yes mentioned they have been some some
other very interesting games in this
round and also I can tell you the
results now cards and Vitara Krishna
actually using the ancient pond siani
opening which i think i really really
spoke many bad terms about and in my
repertoire series for blackie 45 calling
it a bad opening yeah what cars are
played in anyway but how krishna didn't
unfortunately didn't play the line i
suggested and and lost at the end not
due to the opening yeah but i would have
liked to see what magnus has in store
against the recommendation that i was
giving in the video karana beat Sokolov
a nice rule opus wrong how bitter who
you found a very interesting names
minion and interesting minigame then
really also won against Kevin lamby is
compatriot we had this relatively
harmless draw between Geary and Lake oh
and a fighting game between a camera and
Coyoacan where Nakamura probably was
completely winning but someone managed
to to only drop maybe went into some
sort of Perpetual I didn't look at this
well the other game some have been
really interesting as well so I'll go to
them in a separate video maybe tomorrow
if I have the time um but they're not
today this is simply too much yeah
thanks for watching hope you enjoyed
this really great game one of the
candidates for for game of the year
certainly including a great opening idea
with c5 and then this this fireworks I
really love this Bishop c5 ninety takes
d5 completely ignoring those two pawns
simply great and you have this this
night on h7 all the time it's really
bizarre alright thanks for watching I'll
be back tomorrow